How do you get to reading more
than a million words a year in
the language you're learning?
Is that even possible?
Reading is key to so many things in life.
In our own language,
people who read well have
more socioeconomic success.
The statistics prove this.
We have the case of Elon Musk, who
apparently read two books a day.
I think the average book has
70-, 80-, 90,000 words in it.
250, 300 pages or so.
Apparently Warren Buffet
reads 500 pages a day.
So those two gentlemen read
30 plus million words a year.
The average person, according to
statistics, reads—in the US or in
typical European country—14, 15 books
a year, a little more than one a month.
This works out to a little
over a million words a year.
Just in terms of books. But, of course,
we read all kinds of other stuff.
We read newspaper articles online.
We read Twitter, Facebook, and so forth.
So we easily read more than a million
words a year in our own language.
But how does this relate
to language learning?
I think reading is tremendously
powerful in language learning.
I always feel that when I get to
where I can read a book away from
the computer without the help of LingQ,
or, you know, online dictionaries.
That's a major milestone
in my learning activity.
So what about the strategy of
reading a million words in a
language that we're learning?
Obviously it's much more difficult to
read in the language we're learning.
The more different the language is,
and especially if the writing system is
different, it's a lot more difficult.
So if we say that the average person
reads, say, a book a month, and some
people read a book a week, if I
get to where I, you know, this milestone
of reading a book in the language
that I'm learning, I'm not reading a
book a week or even a book a month.
In that language, at least
not for a long, long time.
So I would say, first of all, we
have to make a distinction between
someone like me who is a bit of a
dilettante, and I'm working on Persian and
Arabic, and I throw in some Polish,
versus someone who's learning English.
I think for those of you out there who
are learning English, who are working
on improving your English, you want
to be as good as possible in English.
Maybe you need it for school
or you need it for work.
Then I think the objective is trying to
read at least one book in English a month.
It's realistic and it would be very
beneficial to your language skills.
And the same is true for someone
who is dedicated to one language,
French, Spanish, German, Chinese.
If you can get yourself to where
you can read a book a month in
your target language, it'll have
tremendous benefits. Because reading is
connected to listening and speaking.
We have to remember that
for most of history
humans didn't—and whatever animals
preceded us on the evolutionary
scale—obviously didn't read.
It's not something
natural to human beings.
And for most of that period of
history, when we had writing,
most people didn't read.
So the fact that we are able to
read is a tremendous achievement. And
all kinds of research shows that
it's connected with sound. That when
we develop our ability to read,
we first have to develop this—
what they call "phonemic awareness"
The connection between the
written word and the sound.
And this takes time to develop.
Struggling readers don't hear the
sounds very well, so in dealing
with dyslexic people, or people who
struggle to read in their own language,
increasingly educators are using
teaching methods that connect the sound
to the written word. It's extremely important.
So as a language learner, we are in
the situation of a struggling reader.
We're not struggling to read in our own
language with all of the consequences
that has for socioeconomic success.
And it's a major problem in societies.
You know, weak readers have
difficulty. They're overrepresented
in prisons, and so on and so forth.
Not always, like I know people who don't
read well, who are very successful
at what they do. But largely speaking,
reading is considered a shortcut
to greater socioeconomic success.
If we can improve the performance
of poor readers, it'll have a major
impact for those individuals
and also for society as a whole.
But getting back to language learning.
We want to use the same approach in order
to improve our language learning skills.
So connect audio with
text as much as possible.
That's why at LingQ, for every item
that we have in our libraries,
there is audio and text.
That's why we now, we enable
people to grab an MP3 file
somewhere or from a YouTube video,
or whatever, for their own use.
Of course, there's a limit
to what they can share.
Bring it in.
There's an automatic
transcription created, which
then you can study as a lesson.
The idea is that if you're focused
on one language, you want to get to a
level where you can read a book a month.
That will really propel your language
skills forward because whenever
you read, you are subvocalizing.
We know, science tells us, you know,
MRIs of the brain tell us that the
same portion of our brain is activated
when we read as when we speak or
listen. And this is true whether the
writing system is a pictographic system
like Chinese characters or a syllabary
like the Japanese writing system or
a pure alphabet like Hangul in Korean
or the Latin alphabet or the Arabic
script. The brain performs the same way.
Text connects to audio.
Certainly if we're fairly good in the
language we can follow along at LingQ.
I very much encourage people to
import content of interest to
LingQ where they also have the audio.
Remember that one key
to reading success is that
the content be of interest.
So just as I say at LingQ, we
want people to learn the language
from content of interest.
If you want to increase your reading, go
find things that are of interest to you.
And I know that kids, there
are books that they like for
whatever reason they like them,
like books by Roald Dahl that are
very popular with kids. And now they're
fussing about the wording in those books,
which is so silly because really all
you want is to encourage kids to read.
Nothing that is offensive to any
particular group in any particular book is
gonna have a lasting impact on the reader.
The most important thing is to
get the reader reading, and the
same is true in language learning.
Read things that you enjoy and you
will improve your skills at reading.
You will improve your skills if
you listen to the same content.
You will improve your listening skills.
But there are steps, and if you look at
my statistics at LingQ, you'll see, first
of all, that it's much easier for me to
read in Polish than to read in Persian
or Arabic, even though I have spent far
more time on Persian than on Polish.
So it's not difficult for me to get up
to 50-, 60,000 words a day of reading in
Polish when I'm really on it, whereas
it's much more difficult to do that
in Persian.
In fact, in Polish, I can simply
read through the text, listen to
it while reading if I want, or
listen to it when I'm away from the
computer, come back and read it again
to pick up the words that I missed.
But when I'm in Persian,
I prefer to go through
the lesson in "sentence mode" where the
audio is timestamped to the sentence.
I can closely connect the words to the
audio because I don't yet have that
phonemic awareness in Persian because
the writing system is more obtuse to
me. I'm not so used to it as I am
to the Latin alphabet. And
I should add that in Polish—
and I haven't spent much time in
Polish, but I was over in Poland
and so I imported this ebook into
LingQ and I also was given a copy.
In fact, I was first given a
copy of the book in sort of book
form, traditional book form.
Then I found the
ebook and I imported it.
So now I can go through reading it on
LingQ, looking up words, and then I can
sit down and enjoy the book
in a traditional book format.
And I think this is something well
worth doing, even if you read the
same thing in different formats.
It all contributes.
It's all part of reading.
Can I get in polish to where
I read a million words a year?
In other words, a book a month or
a little more than a book a month?
If I lived in Poland,
if Polish were the only language
I was learning, I think I could
get there. And I think I would
make it an objective to get there.
Now, if we step back to Persian,
it's so much more difficult for me.
If I lived in Iran and if I had to get
to that level, I think I would set myself
the goal of trying to read a book in
Persian, you know, as a goal, one a month.
I think I could get there.
Part of it is, when reading away
from the computer, as I did with this
other book on the, the History of
Krakow, ignore the words you don't know.
In other words, get yourself
to a level using, you know,
reading online, looking at words.
Get yourself to a level where
you can still more or less follow
the gist of what you're reading
without having to look up words.
Because looking up words very much slows
you down and it's much faster to do that
reading online where you have, you know,
a quick reference to an online dictionary
and the other functionality that's
available in an application like LingQ,
to acquire vocabulary.
But the goal, if you are dedicated
to one language and you genuinely
want to become fluent in that
language, the goal of reading a
million words a year is attainable.
And I should add, because not
everything you read is gonna be a book.
So if you read a book a week, You don't
have to get to the level of Elon Musk or
Warren Buffet, and I might add in there
Bill Gates, who claims, I think, that he
reads 50 books a year, which isn't in
the 30 million words a year, but it's
in more than 3 million words a year.
You don't even have to get to that level.
If you read a book a week in your target
language, you will definitely surpass
a million words a year because
you do reading of articles, of
newspaper articles, social media.
But if you are committed to becoming,
call it "C1" in your target language, then
you should be able to read a book a week.
And if you can combine it with
listening, so combination ebook-audiobook,
if you can combine the two,
Because reading is so intimately—in
our brains—connected with listening,
then you are going to dramatically
improve your ability to read,
your familiarity with the language.
All of those things in your
brain are gonna be activated.
So I think that's a laudable
goal and an achievable goal.
Although I admit that with me in
Persian, it's still a long way away.
And because I'm not dedicated to one
language, I probably won't achieve it.
But for those of you who are, you
know, determined to really kind of
ratchet up your skill level in a
language, a million words a year is not
a difficult goal for you to achieve.
And there will be many, many
benefits across your language skills.
Thank you for listening.
Bye for now.